[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants je me demande ce que
nos deux petits coquins de nicolas et
pimprenelle peuvent bien faire ce soir
jeffrey pts john ware poteau
oui descend vite nounours et gronde
l'est s'ils ne sont pas sages vous connu
au long du look du coup beaucoup
beaucoup oui oui et oui non ou soit pas
mal moi je regarde comme elle est
vilaine
je regarde tu sais ma grande soeur elle
veut pas manger sa soupe
or ce n'est pas bien ça bonsoir ma
petite apple à grenelle est non
seulement alors pas preneur on ne veut
pas manger sa soupe
ce n'est pas bien du tout ça c'est pas
bien du tout vit pas bien du tout moi
j'ai mangé bassoues lassouts
ça fait grotte et moi grandir tralala ah
non vous regarde toute petite cuillère
pour nicolas allons soit raisonnable pas
pr tél
j'ai très facile de manger sa soupe on
prend un morceau de pain ou le trempe de
dons comme ça
ce bond à toi maintenant avec nicolas on
va encourager
oui ça nous encourage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
mais tu pleures - gosso deux fois l'open
tard le trackball 7 sous alors une
petite cuillère là encore une autre là
une dernière là et bien voilà je n'étais
pas bien difficile allons c'est fini on
ne pleure plus vite aux totaux ou nikola
saleh annonce julie je suis grand moi
c'est très bien nicolas se dégrade
non aujourd'hui pape rebelles tu n'es
pas très grande
[Musique]
je promets que je mangerai tout masquer
des mains et moi aussi comme ça je
serais encore plus grand je compte sur
vous et petits à long terme eu deux
années là
bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et vous aussi les petits enfants vous
devez toujours manger votre soupe
moi je la mange toujours massou c'est
très bien nounours mais toi tu n'es plus
un enfant tu es grand je me sens encore
tellement en font pas trop il seulement
bon là sous alan en route
mon bon nounours en août mon patron
bonne nuit fais de duren peu de tours
bordeaux
[Musique]
e